good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy to use day hey
jax how you doing i'm doing good we're
the green girls today we're green with
envy
if you're watching on youtube get a load
of the screen yeah maybe you don't see
us because it's a green screen but if
you're listening as a podcast you're
like what the [__] are you talking about
we don't care move on no here's what
we're saying we're both wearing green
yeah we're green girlies we didn't even
plan to
match up like this to be so green we're
so simpatico
so
so green
um happy tuesday um it is only tuesday
but it is a short week because it's july
4th so thank god for that
so it's making it quite bearable quite
digestible you know what i'm so busy
this week that i actually don't even
have time to like ruminate on what day
it is and it's one of those weeks where
i hate to be one of those people but
there's just like
not enough time oh my god there's plenty
of time i don't know like i'm so booked
and busy today
that it being early in the week actually
allows me
to potentially get everything done that
i need to get done i feel that do you
have no time to lament
yeah because i'm doing podcast podcast
podcasts book club book club book club
meetings meetings meetings spray tan
spray tan spray tan
to piggyback off of that speaking of um
podcast podcast podcast we have a very
special announcement today um so i just
dropped an episode on shannon ford's
podcast she interviewed me it was super
fun this was like a few weeks ago and we
announced on there that shannon is
joining tnn for the second season of her
podcast she's wrapping up the first
season now and the second season comes
out at the end of the summer and
starting then she will officially be a
tnn girly you know mogul energy
radiating mogul supporting moguls yeah
it's very exciting shannon is so premium
like her podcasts are so good she does
them all on video and audio and she like
is always to the nines glammed up she's
just one of those people who is
beautiful on the inside and the outside
she's so interesting she's born to
podcast she
is so good when she's been on this show
or even just like her instagram stories
everything she does is premium and i
can't think of a better home than tnn
you know what actually um you just
reminded me of something when we had all
those guest co-hosts come when you were
on maternity leave our most listened to
guest co-host episode was shannon so
like the toasters crave shannon shannon
craves the toasters and now it's just a
gorgeous blend of shannon toaster energy
yeah i started listening to your podcast
episode this morning it was so good and
i listened as a podcast instead of
watching so i was like getting ready so
i was just being like a podcast an audio
girl an audio girl as so many of you are
out there and it's really a premium
experience um but i was just like loving
her like admitting that she's obsessed
with us and it's like if only she like i
know you told her how obsessed you are
but i don't think she understands no
like
normalize acknowledging being obsessed
with people because like more often than
not like the feeling is mutual sometimes
it's not yeah but i do feel like
sometimes people like overuse that trope
like i'm obsessed with you and it's like
there's a difference between that
whatever that is and how we feel about
channeling no i literally reply to every
single one of her instagram stories hey
where's that dress from like as if i
could wear the same dress as [__]
shadow before she's six feet tall um i'm
like hey what are you doing hey are you
in the city i'm like i'm a freak you
know when i see she's in new york i'm
like giddy i'm like good oh a text
should be coming like this is great for
new york and now we have her in our
grasp yeah and she can never let go yeah
so that's very exciting and then also
speaking of book club i wanted to tell
you that so i finished the book that you
selected for the redheads on sunday and
you're recording the episode today and
it comes out thursday right yeah july
7th though like the first thursday of
july why because i was actually thinking
about dropping it the redheads you know
we are like death and taxes you can
always rely that will be there just
every once in a while it's the second
thursday of the month but you know
things happen but they push back tax day
sometimes ex thanks every once in a
while every once in a while like when
there's something really big and the
girls like can't find the day that works
for people with four very busy schedules
but because we're recording the episode
early and it is a holiday weekend like
and people have read the book or reading
the book over the weekend like maybe
it's something that you need to take
with you into the weekend and like maybe
we'll bump it up so i thought it was
coming out this thursday and i wasn't
gonna read another book until then
because like i find it confusing i
sometimes i read a book and then i read
another one and that previous book is
just gone in my memory so you wanted to
listen to the episode on thursday well
regardless of when it drops officially i
can always send it to you oh that's true
that's true because i really want to
experience like in real time yeah the
redheads effect because i'm always you
know two years late to the party i will
send it to you when we're done with it
but i was thinking about dropping it
early so let me know what you think
about that idea um and then the other
thing i wanted to talk about was how we
literally turned into the number one
mental health podcast on the planet
yesterday i cannot tell you how many
messages i got from two groups of people
mostly from people who have had
intrusive thoughts and were like so
embarrassed and petrified to ever admit
it out loud yeah and like not even seek
therapy because they thought they would
be diagnosed as like a serial killer
right when it's actually so normal yeah
and i guess i realized i don't think i
was ever comfortable about talking my
about my intrusive thoughts until my
friend abe mentioned one that he had
that was so
like my brain i was like how do you know
that and then he was like no my
therapist told me it's like so common so
now i feel like cool talking about it
but if you've ever had them and you
don't know what it is like you're like
i'm a horrible scary person right like
thinking about like throwing your
newborn baby down the stairs like yeah
that's what i've seen also i thought
when people were saying intrusive
thoughts they just meant like you know
general anxiety worrying about the world
the worst possible things that can
happen but that's not that no intrusive
thoughts are the ones that just like
you know having a lovely moment and they
just like come out of nowhere and it's
like the worst thing you could do and
it's also like you acting not something
happening yeah you know so i like
i'm really glad i brought it up because
i feel like a lot of people yesterday on
the podcast had that moment that i had
with my friend abe like years ago so
it's totally normal i had that moment
where i'm like oh that's what intrusive
thoughts are and i know exactly what
you're talking about so you're not crazy
thank god yeah also the second group of
people i got a lot of messages from were
like micro influencers being like thank
you so much for the segment on
influencers like i had a lot of tagged
in stories of like people like you know
under 20 000 followers just being like
this is such a good episode oh my god
that's so great so we're out here
representing the influencer community
influencer community and the mental
health community and that's really all
you can ask for yeah i love that um so
that's really all i had to add to life
today
oh except i know i've been keeping
everyone up to abreast on my sleeping
journey and i know like nobody cares but
like this is how we got into the
intrusive thoughts conversation
yesterday because i took melatonin and i
slept really good so i took melatonin
again and i went to bed at 10 o'clock i
woke up at 2am and i was up till 5. whoa
it was horrible you know what i thought
there was nothing worse than not being
able to fall asleep no
sleeping waking up for a few hours then
going back to sleep is the worst thing
on the planet okay so no more melatonin
because also like melatonin yeah you
sleep so good so you take it again and
again and then eventually it stops
working and then you're just like hooked
so just quit while you're ahead i know i
just like want to be able to sleep like
i always look at theo and i
i am envious of so many things in theo's
life like he doesn't have to pay bills
he doesn't have you know the weight of
the world on his shoulders and he also
doesn't ever have to worry about falling
asleep he closes his eyes boom asleep
yeah nothing really keeps him up at
night but that's also because he kind of
has his life in order you know he's a
responsible
adult and like he doesn't leave these
things hanging that keep him up at night
that's true but like i just crave that
sort of mindless
energy yeah well what if you took like a
really hot bath but right before bed not
like at six o'clock so i'm at a place
like in my life and my physical journey
where like i just really don't
like fit in my bathtub anymore i have a
really small bathtub and when i first
moved into the apartment like it was
tight yeah but you'd grow but it was
doable um i've grown enormously in width
and i'm sure i could fit but it's just
like who wants to be like sausage into
like a sardine yeah even though i will
say um today marks the date where i lost
15 pounds
and i'm really proud of myself because
i've just been trying to thank you cut
back a little bit you know it's
summertime the chub rub is out of
control um and i definitely look and
feel the same way so that's awesome it's
really great
um so maybe i should try getting back in
the tub
yeah yeah yeah you need to lose
people like what's your goal weight i'm
like i just want to fit in my tub yeah
but like i don't want to like be
dramatic my tub is so small yeah no but
also like sure you fit into it but like
you want to splay out i can't really
spread my life to come and use my tubs
you don't even like baths i i started
taking baths more i take baths more i
used to never huge deep tub that you
know
literally like
drown in it it's so big and yeah there's
a big window
overlooks the city i don't know what
they can see and i don't want to think
about it yeah like their problem not
much yeah 100 um it's really wonderful
you should come over for a sleepover one
night i would love that and you should
use my tub i just need a bath like i
used to be such a bath girlie and i
haven't taken a bath time q a right and
brand is suffering no and people are
always like bring back the bath time q
and am like girly i can't fit
so that was part of like the impetus
behind seeing the snow before christmas
when i wanted to move last year um a tub
was like a huge thing for me i'll even
take a good tub in the guest bathroom
like i just need one good tub because
i'm normally a shower but like i don't
know there's nothing like a midday tub
no but like if you did a late night tub
you might have an easier time relaxing
no i know
like
there's i go through periods in my life
where like sleep evades me and it makes
me
abnormally enraged like it's so annoying
yeah also maybe try
a
physical book not the kindle because i
do like i feel like whenever i read a
physical book i'm like this [__] sucks
that's true it's so boring i'm sleepy
good night that's a good call and i do
wonder sometimes if the kindle has um
blue light blue light i read like the
most misleading study like i was looking
for now with the redheads we do like a
book news segment and now that i started
it like there's no book news so i have
to like go searching and i saw this
dumbass npr article that was like
reading on an e-reader like makes you
makes it harder for readers to fall
asleep and i was like oh okay click let
me read about this study they literally
sampled 10 people that's why you need to
read the fine print because that doesn't
tell you [__] about a grade a grade
agreed agreed and like what were these
10 people going through like right what
was on their mind maybe they had their
lives together like theo like yeah maybe
they couldn't sleep because like rent
was due or like other things that were
keeping them up yeah yeah that's moronic
in order for a study to be like actually
legit i think you need to do like 100
people
that's i don't think that's like legit i
think the bigger the study you know the
more legit but yeah ten's not not gonna
cut it npr and i can't believe they
would even like push that forward no
that's like embarrassing for the public
radio community yeah
what is the end stand for national
national cool
yeah yeah
um so we've got a great show
we've got five stories um we have an
interview that we're doing today are we
releasing it today we're going to see
youtube like
today and then it will be in the podcast
tomorrow i feel like that's fair i feel
like that's fair too so if you want the
exclusive obviously subscribe so you
know when it happens that's the thing
about being a subscriber you get
exclusive content and you're subscribed
and you're good in my book so you know
where else you got exclusive content
patreon and we recorded a podcast
yesterday that will go up today so if
you need extra content we've got you and
it's so good and so funny it's all about
things that give you the ick like that
people do that you know potential
partners do and how you could be falling
in love with someone and then you have
to like wait online with them and it's
over it's dead fizzled it's such a good
funny episode and head over to
patreon.com for more good funny episodes
um because there are so many so many and
if you're not a patron and you join
today like there's 250 plus episodes in
the morning toast waiting for you
7.99 particularly unhinged yeah no i
feel much more comfortable like it's
more of a safe space on patreon because
if you're paying for content like more
likely than not like you're not a troll
yeah but don't get me wrong there are
trolls who will go to the length of
paying seven dollars they will and they
don't know this yet i'm here to tell
them
that they are fans thank you so much for
your support we really appreciate it you
know what we were talking about this
yesterday about how like i've recently
become obsessed with one particular
influencer i will like literally never
say their name um and um it's like a
hate watching thing but you're a true
fan i guess i am yeah no and like that's
beautiful yeah and even though you might
have come to it in a non-traditional way
through the route of hate like you're a
fan you're supporting her work and i
love that for both of you yeah
you're giving a view yeah but you're
getting like you enjoy yeah for sure
it's just like not your typical enjoy in
a negative way
yeah but like enjoyment is enjoyment
that's
put that on the canva program enjoyment
is enjoyment i'm so excited right let's
dive right into the fast life stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
figs figs is on a mission to take
awesome scrubs suited for the awesome
humans working in healthcare so forget
the boxy itchy scrubs figs are
engineered to be ridiculously soft and
incredibly durable they use innovative
technical comfort technology
fixes blending smooth comfort style and
durability into high performance scrubs
that help you perform at your best
whatever the day throws at you so figs
are functional they're modern scrubs
with a focus on design function and
comfort their proprietary four-way
stretch fabric for a ridiculously soft
feel their moisture-wicking anti-wrinkle
and anti-odor thanks to the silvador
anti-microbial technology if you don't
know where to start at figs they're
super popular core scrubs never go out
of stock or style i have actually core
scrubs because i um love to lounge
around in stretchy
materials and i don't discriminate
whether they're scrubs or whatever you
know yes comfort is come comfort is
comfort and figs are premium so if
there's like a healthcare worker in your
life who you want to surprise with
something nice i feel like it makes a
huge difference in your day like how
much you feel comfortable in your
clothing like you'll perform better
you'll feel better um so check out figs
they believe that awesome humans in
healthcare deserve scrubs that match
head to wherefigs.com and use code toast
to get 15 off your first order that's
w-e-a-r-f-i-g-s
dot com code toast for 15 off your first
order
thank you claudia our first story is a
story that i'm weirdly very invested in
charlie dimlio and landon barker are
dating its early stages says thesaurus
to people magazine so the tick tock star
and entrepreneur is dating drummer
travis barker's son who's also a
musician and budding fashion designer a
source tells people exclusively they say
quote they're seeing each other and it's
early stages the stars are both 18. we
love a age appropriate relationship this
is so cute you know what's so
interesting to me is how like punk rock
is like making the biggest comeback
of course when we think of like blink
182 and just like that genre of music
i'm in love with an emo girl it's giving
like early 2000s yeah but not even
through music but i think like through
celebrity punk is becoming like cool
again and it's so interesting how it's
like trickling down from like 40 year
olds like the kardashians to 18 year
olds like charlie everybody's choosing
the punk rockers mgk yeah travis now
landon even um addison ray's boyfriend
is a punk rocker who plays with mgk and
uh travis okay this is i'm glad you
brought her up because this story is
really interesting to me because i
always like associate charlie and
addison even though they're different
ages like they're the tick tock girlies
and it's like
even though there's trouble in paradise
between addison and courtney like
addison is friends with courtney and
then like charlie's dating her son you
know i thought the same thing it's just
like two different levels yeah it's just
interesting and also now it's like i
don't even know if addison and charlie
are friends i'm sure they're you know
acquaintances but now if like the whole
punk rock crew is getting together
then addison and charlie are going to be
hanging out well so do you have
confirmed proof that there's trouble in
paradise between courtney she wasn't at
the wedding and i'm sorry like the size
of the wedding and considering how close
they were last summer she should have
been invited yeah but there's no like
concrete proof that they're not friends
anymore no and i don't think they're
probably i don't think they're like
enemies but they were close and now
they're less close i wonder if courtney
still follows addison i'm sure she does
i don't think there's beef right i think
that they are less close
and that's sad
yeah because they were so close no and
it was like an iconic
albeit bizarre friendship yeah
so yeah my thought immediately also went
to like
courtney and charlie
i know and she's like so bizarre like
courtney loves the tick tockers i'm sure
mason is thrilled about this oh my god i
forgot how literally this would affect
mason it's really it's quite beautiful
you couldn't write a better relation i
couldn't like if we put our list
together of 18 year olds i would never
even have thought to put them together
no but also this is just like an
interesting moment in kardashian history
where like they're also now being
brought into the next generation in
terms of like relevance
they're not really like aging out of
this tick tock age because like now
they're kids this is like this i mean
it's travis's kid but it's courtney's
stepchild and it's like it's the second
generation of kardashians like and their
fame like this is just the star cause
like you know north pretty soon is gonna
be on the cover of magazines like this
is just the beginning of kardashian gen
2.0 taking the lead yeah
it's so crazy i really ship
i really do he's a nice boy from what
we've seen on kardashians and charlie's
a nice girl too you know i don't think
they're gonna be getting into trouble
are we gonna get season two of the
demilio show yes we are i'm gonna be
watching it they went to the hulu like
up fronts to promote because i don't
remember what i said about it by the
time i finished this i remember what did
i say you were really shocked at how
much like mental health but did i enjoy
the show what did i say about that i
think you did i think i did you finished
it the way that i look back on it like
was filled with so much tea and insight
and like i never would have expected
like this is these girls day to day
and i want more yeah
i want more i i fully like
the show and i definitely will be
watching it um i do hope it's like a
little more
like a little deeper this time i feel
like it was a little surface level
especially with charlie not with dixie
but like
this is the thing and it's the same with
the kardashians like i don't know when
they filmed it but like dixie just
released an album she's like playing at
all these i heart radio jingle balls
she's doing this cover that's going
viral before he cheats by carrie
underwood like that's what i want to see
and like i think they've stopped filming
months ago you know what i mean it's
like this delayed gratification
especially with social media influencers
it's like it doesn't work wait and also
they're both like hulu family yes do you
think this is pr
i don't think they would use 18 like
they're too young wait that's a good
call no i don't because the relationship
like makes a lot of sense i know but
like they're both like the first
families of hulu
yes however
um aside from this report like if you're
in the tick tocking world which i am
like you've seen like videos of them
like leaving and going to parties
together for like a couple months it's
not like a random blast okay it seemed
pretty organic okay okay great love it
yeah how do you think lil hootie is
handling this uh i don't know him i'm so
like i just don't know okay but they're
friends right but charlie obviously has
a type because like lil hootie is also
like a more of like an emo punk musician
like really they look kind of similar
like black shaggy hair tall and skinny
like charlie obviously has a type yeah
we love a consistent queen we do
but in the show like her and uh huddy
are friends
so they can still be friends even though
she has a new man yeah i think a lot of
people took that friendship as like the
building blocks to getting back together
i didn't see sparks between them i did
not at the beginning no i literally
don't know them whatsoever no same
um i just also think that like this is
an interesting moment in time for the
talkers as well because i definitely
think just in terms of fame like the
addison and charlie's like they peaked
and
i just feel like at for a while i was
like addison is doing everything right
but now i'm kind of seeing like how they
both played with the
cards they were dealt like the emilios
were much more i think like long-term
focus like they started a 25 million
venture capitalist fund like they're
like in it for the for the long haul
like they're being really smart um and
addison just feels like she's been so
distant lately but to me the addison
distance feels like a choice not us a
byproduct of choices that she made like
i feel like she's always on vacation
right now like focusing on herself and
her happiness i think she's like movie
roles lined up but
is working less because she's enjoying
her life not because people aren't
hiring her we'll see we'll have to say
we shall see i miss addison though that
was like a really fun time when she was
everywhere and she's all that was
everything was all that
she was all that truly
i look forward to her next leading role
me too
lady are you ready for our next story
speaking of celebrity spawn yes ben
affleck's son samuel aged 10
accidentally backs into a lamborghini in
a bmw wait l.a dealership age 10 age 10
do you not see this story ben affleck i
got a people notification but it didn't
register for me that a 10 year old was
behind the wheel right okay so ben
affleck's son samuel garner that's
interesting that he has his mom's last
name oh progress very interesting got
into a fender bender while visiting a
luxury car rental dealership over the
weekend so he was with his dad and j lo
at 777 exotics in la where ben let his
preteen get into the driver's seat of a
yellow lamborghini while in the vehicle
he hit a white bmw station behind him
the car was on yeah he like was tested
he was trying out cars in a dealership
the ten-year-old wanted to get in the
front seat so he did and he accidentally
backed up into another car it wasn't a
big deal and there weren't like marks on
the car but like ben was really upset
according to all these sources but yeah
sounds
i know yeah no he
i'm not judging like i'm not parent
shaming like what the [__] are you doing
yeah your kid is 10 years old and it's
not like you're you're literally in a
lamborghini exotic what the [__] are you
doing i think this was just like a
moment where he just like forgot who he
was where he was the ages and it's like
oh we're in a dealership like he's not
going on the street like let him get in
the front seat ha ha not funny
how did his feet even reach the pedals
like the story is so confusing maybe
he's a tall child tall for his age what
do you think the damage was like
monetarily you didn't walk out scot-free
oh yeah i don't know what the damage was
but i think more like the damage to his
image is worse like no i mean this is so
embarrassing and i feel like jennifer
gardner is like a very strict moment
she's not happy when she heard that like
her ex-husband let their 10 year old get
in the front seat of a sports car that
was on
oh he got his ass [__] ripped when
when he got bored
i could just like imagine
how he felt and then how she felt
hearing it yeah yeah but him like
knowing like it's
he's in trouble and the whole world
knows
like it's just bad it's bad what do you
think the relationship between j.lo and
jay garner is
i think it's bad because yes because of
the history
because of the history
even though like when jennifer gardner
and ben affleck did get divorced it was
like very much her decision she found
happiness immediately with someone
afterwards like she was the one but it
can't feel good that like the man even
if it was your decision to break up the
marriage it can't feel good that the man
you shared a life with for so many years
ended up back with the woman yeah that
he was with before i think before these
two got back together i'm sure jlo like
resented jennifer garner because like
she got
you know she's actually
and she got him to the finish line and
like that was the the you know the next
girl and like she resented her and now
like it goes both ways yeah all the
years like jacob spent thinking about
jennifer gardner jennifer garner is now
spent thinking about james i think
there's mutual hate but but when you are
co-parenting and you're in a new
relationship but you have to get along
but i also think as co-parents like they
probably don't speak i think they do
like the bare minimum communication by
the way i don't know these people it's
just just surviving getting yeah but i
feel like you know some co-parents like
are involved and you know blended and
others just like texts about the kids
and i think it feels like a text about
the kids situation and i think ben and
jennifer garner barely speaks so j lo
and jen garner no
yeah but like if they do get married and
like
the kids are gonna like spend time with
jayla like jennifer garner's gonna need
to know that like her kids are safe with
jlo and i know they are but like you
have to communicate like that's honestly
when i think about co-parenting like in
a hypothetical situation like
not i feel two ways about it i would
make my blood [__] boil like get your
[__] disgusting hands off my kids
yeah but
it's also like wow another person wants
to take care of my kids so i can go on
vacation sign me up like i don't know
where i would fall i think it depends on
the person yeah and it also depends on
how your message ended yes but like
if the person is someone i mean maybe
you could never see them in a favorable
light if you if there's all these other
residual feelings but if it was some
like
you know
bad meredith like oh well that that's
not even what i'm thinking about i'm
just thinking about like
i don't know maybe like an air ahead
yeah well like that's like if someone
getting into a relationship like with a
much younger woman which does happen a
lot yeah and then it's weird it's like
you also feel like is this 25 year old
prepared to take care of my adult child
not my teenage children right right
there's so many things that go into it
it can be done you can blend sure
but there's a lot of factors but people
who do it like seamlessly and very
maturely and like put the kids first
have my utmost respect like i think
there's nothing harder mm-hmm
yeah because there are so many dynamics
right and people can be you know
everyone has their individual
personalities no and parenting is like
so personal like your choices when it
comes to your kids are like everyone has
the best intentions but what you choose
might like literally someone else might
think is so crazy yeah yeah yeah
i hope i never get there well speaking
of parenting our next story chris pratt
cried over the backlash from his post
praising his quote healthy daughter do
you remember this remind me chris pratt
uh
went on instagram to talk like glo about
his wife and he was like find someone
who looks at you oh yes catherine looks
at me and then he said like she's giving
me beautiful healthy daughters she gave
me a beautiful healthy daughter and
everyone thought that was like a slime
at his son with anapharys because he has
like some health issues he was premature
he was seven weeks premature and he was
in the niku okay so everyone thought
that that's what it was and now he's on
the cover of men's health and he's
saying that that whole situation made
him cry i feel like he's always on the
cover of men's health you know yeah uh
he's always on the cover like of
something these pictures are actually
really cute
and like dad like chris pratt is hot
like oh for sure everybody knows that
but like look at him on the cover he's
like being like men's healthy but also
like dad body and i feel like people
don't really talk about the evolution of
chris pratt literally it's all people
talk about when he was like playing only
like the fat funny friend and then he
like went on a diet and became a leading
man like first of all how [__] up was
that like you can't be chubby and a
leading man but his evolution is really
interesting to me i don't think about it
he never lost his chubby energy no and
by the way and that's why he has staying
power i'm so glad you brought that up
chubby energy is so important like i
feel like we talk about celebrities like
weight loss journeys a lot um and for me
like as a
chubby
fat okay fat person like i i can't lie
and say like when a when someone gets
famous for being big and then not for
being big they get famous when they're
big and then they lose weight like when
they get really famous like it does feel
like a little bit like a betrayal
um
but what really feels like the betrayal
is like they lose that spark you know
yeah when you are a heavy person
especially in entertainment so you're
like one of the only you have to work
much harder to be like funnier and
charismatic you you work extra hard on
your personality because other people
don't have to do that they can rely on
their looks in entertainment which is
like a looks based industry so i always
feel sad for like the the loss of the
spark yeah but do you think that you
feel differently when it's a man versus
a woman like maybe you feel me
give me an example of a man who's lost a
lot of weight and like changed his
like
like and lost his chubby spark no just
give me and i'll tell you if he lost to
chevy spark jonah hill
lost his chubby spark
okay still a little bit there but not
nearly as much um and then the female
category melissa mccarthy like rebel
will rebel will send him out i don't
know if rebel lost her spark it's too
soon to tell you know there's too much
rmn going around we can't sift through
and see where the spark is i would be
lying if i said melissa mccarthy didn't
lose a little bit of her spark she
became like a really serious actor but
she's also just like choosing different
roles yeah which is a part of that you
have more options which is so [__] up
like you have so many more options at
one weight than you do at another like
when you're plus size in hollywood like
you are constantly fat funny friend yeah
and you know what melissa mccarthy
was the one of the most successful
overweight actresses because she had
movie after movie that was her movie
like she wasn't friend of supporting
role it was her movie but she was like
this comically self-deprecating
character but you know what good for her
she definitely moved the needle yeah
and i don't mean this as an insult at
all like i just find it to be like a
genuinely interesting observation yeah
so back to his kid he never lost his
chubby energy and he's saying that you
know people who were saying was a dig at
his wife he said quote that is [__] up
my son's going to read that one day he's
nine and it's etched in digital stone it
really [__] bothered me dude i cried
about it i mean i feel that that is
bothersome because saying like i love my
wife she gave me a healthy child is a
very common thing to say
people i think we're looking too much
into it and i do believe that was the
takeaway we had when we reported on it
like last year or whatever um and i can
see that bothering him and he has every
right for it to bother him yeah
that's messed up it is messed up but um
they also just had another baby right
yeah uh they're still a little key oh
that's a cute name really cute and they
have another daughter laila the one who
was beautiful healthy daughter got it
got it and what's his name his son's
name with a friend jack does anna paris
date
i'm sure i wonder what she's getting
into i'm sure she's doing her thing
i'm gonna do my thing
[Music]
i'm gonna do my thang
the town of paris getting ready for a
date anna paris
is like such an iconic actress i wish
she would act more no she really isn't
that people who have worked with her say
like the most glowing things about her
acting like she was in that movie that
everyone's obsessed with lost in
translation you know
she was like uh
she wasn't like she was in like a
comedic role and the movie's about like
scar joe and tom hanks but i remember
reading like tom hanks like was taken
with anna paris oh i'd love to hear that
obviously like my extend my knowledge of
anna ferris's work is more like house
bunny
um
just friends what's my number what's
your number just friends and i think
like just friends that was the same
takeaway from like the people on set for
that movie i love to hear that and i'm
sure she's a delight to work with yeah
and i just really wish her the best like
i do love a queen who respects podcasts
but i need her to get back on the horse
like it's time for another rom-com yeah
i'm ready
um
ready
i'm ready too but not before i let you
know that the rest of the show was
brought to you by zip recruiter we must
know this we're all so excited to travel
this summer but have you ever thought
about all the people that it takes to
make a vacation truly great well you
know that outstanding talent is crucial
for a successful business and if you're
hiring you can find talent for roles
like these and more at zip recruiter
when you try it for free at
ziprecruiter.com
toast so you know a vacation like when
you go on a trip if the concierge is
like so above and beyond helpful all the
staff is just like so kind welcoming and
warm and that's all about just like
having a good hiring experience and
ziprecruiter is it they use powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job you can
easily review these recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply additionally ziprecruiter has
complete suite of tools that makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates four out of five employers
who post on zip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day it's no
wonder the zip recruiter is the number
one rated hiring site based on g2
satisfaction ratings as of january 2022
so travel
to this easy to remember destination
ziprecruiter.com toast that's where you
can try ziprecruiter for free again
that's zip recruiter.com t-o-a-s-t
recruiter the smartest way to hire
today's episode is also brought to you
by slottomania life's too short for a
day without fun get a thrill whenever
you need it at slottomania the world's
number one free slot game you'll have
endless excitement at your fingertips
with 170 free-to-play slot games huge
jackpots and interactive community and a
million free coins so you can join the
biggest community of slot lovers in the
world you can interact with fellow
players form cooperatives slaughter cans
with new friends or you can enter
electrifying live tournaments you can
also become a vip member to get your own
personal account manager connect with
millions of other slot fans on the
slatomania facebook app
facebook page the biggest slot community
in the world you can share your wins
with the world get love and feedback
from other members 24 7. so it's a
really unique gaming experience they
have gorgeous graphics huge jackpots fun
freebies and mini games and there's
something new every day for an endless
variety of fun and the rush you feel
when you win a big jackpot i mean you
know me i'm a gambling girly i love the
casino i love playing on my phone it's
everything of the sort when your day is
feeling stale just ask what will today
spin if you're 21 or older you can join
millions of players around the world
download slot oh mania the number one
free slots game on the app store or
google play store and get a million free
coins that's slotto mania on the app
store or google play store for a million
free coins okay our next story some
glowing kardashian news kris jenner
honors khloe kardashian her 38th
birthday party saying you are the queen
of our family so yesterday was chloe's
birthday and the tributes were coming
and they didn't stop coming okay but
did you notice
maybe i missed it because i went to bed
early that chloe nor
kylie nor kendall posted for chloe what
let me just double check kylie jenner in
feed
no
and she has no stories in the last 24
hours maybe she's just like on a social
media break kendall
infeed no last picture is the one of her
ass
um was she and no story oh she was at
the birthday party and posted a picture
of chris okay but she was at the
birthday party they're obviously not on
the outs if she was there it's just
weird no like the kardashians are always
on schedule with birthday posts like i'm
sure they have like a google doc with
captions and photos i thought that was
interesting that is interesting there
was a party at chris's house last night
she made a drunken toast to chloe who
she said is the queen of our family
um and everyone was just celebrating
coco which we love but check your phone
because kim just posted a carousel of
photos from
from north's birthday camp north and
look what she look at the
look at the weekend look at the moment
camp north they flew kim's plane oh to
like this wilderness outdoor adventure
it looks like kim's like all of north's
friends it literally looks like him toes
it looks like a joke because she had
jessica simpson that's her kid
oh my god i love
that looks like a dream oh my god and
the inside of the plane is decorated
with like cl like
camp logs and [__] like that they slept
in little tents oh my this is so cute
they went
like ropes course like yeah yeah it
looks like camtos and also remember that
episode of kardashians where kim was
saying that north is obsessed with
camping and they had to go camping with
like tracy she should send north to like
camp yes she should do you think north
could go to camp i'm sure there's like
very elite camps yeah where she could
have her oh my god this is so cute by
the way i'm like i'm
falling over jessica simpson in two
photos what's her oldest daughter's name
birdie or max they're
maxie drew
cute i love this so much i love this
aesthetic
i wonder where this is it looks
beautiful this is campgrounds maybe it's
like wyoming or montana yeah i mean
they're near so many or even like
sir
yeah that where they went on chelsea
sunset where they went camping it was
like so nice it doesn't look like the
sir sir the towel it doesn't look like a
sexy unique restaurant it doesn't look
like big sur okay back to this okay back
to chloe's birthday um you know what
this makes me think you know when it's
your birthday and like you're seeing
someone new and it's like either they do
something for you it accelerates it or
it's like you didn't recognize my
birthday you didn't even like get me a
flower or anything like you obviously
don't care about me moving on
if she does have a businessman bow like
this could be a true test yes i always
feel like if it's the right relationship
like your birthday or the other person's
birthday will come at a really good time
to either like move the relationship
forward a little bit faster than normal
or completely derail it and it's like a
sign whether the relationship is meant
to work so i was thinking that too um
the birthday party looked like so it was
like a dinner party it looked very like
elegant of course chef everyone was
wearing gowns and diamonds it was very
low-key um and it looked so fun and so
nice and kim posted a bunch of stories
mostly of kris jenner being wasted um
but she did when they were all sitting
at the table and chris was giving um the
speech she flipped the camera to chloe
and she had to like swerve around the
table i was literally like looking at
every person's face like who is that who
was that all i really saw was malika
chloe and then like this old man in the
back i don't think that was her business
member um
but you never know you never know you
never know whatever's gonna make chloe
happy i just like i really hope he was
there even though like that one singular
report like we got nothing new
in the picture yeah i don't know i was
thinking who is that but he got a
premium spot and he's like the head of
the table yeah if anybody knows this man
please let us know it's so random that
is so funny but i didn't really get to
see like a good viewing of who was truly
there yeah true was there that's who was
truly there um i also was obsessed with
chris you know i'm entering like my
coastal grandmother aesthetic and not
chris isn't coastal grandmother she's
like elevated like
hollywood bran
um so i'm definitely like i'm interested
in what she's serving up she looked so
glamorous in that like big gown yeah and
chloe looks amazing chloe looks amazing
all the girls are looking great yeah i
would love to know like why kendall
didn't post i agree with you like
kylie's not that alarming because they
said on the show like kylie goes through
bouts where she decides like not to put
stormy on social media not to go on
social media so that doesn't really like
perplexed me but like the kendall thing
does especially because she literally
posted one day i got a picture of her
bear ass like she's obviously
engaging she has the app on her phone
you know yeah i agree that is that is
kind of just something to note but she
was at the party so
whatever that means also speaking of
hulu i just told claudia but the new
season of only murders in the building
premieres tonight so that's really
exciting two episodes it is really
exciting i saw some like footage from
the red carpet um of celina i'm looking
glamorous it's gotta keep an eye out for
celina and sometimes like i just sit
back and think about my journey with so
with selena gomez and like it really
it shocks me like how i used to like not
like her at all and like now i'm i can't
get enough like can't get rare beauty
give it yeah only murders need it
selena everything yeah if you had told
me like 10 years ago that there would be
a time when i was like more obsessed
with selena than miley like yeah i would
say who was this traitor yeah that's so
true out of my face that's so true yeah
i have a couple people like that
obviously miranda lambert comes to mind
right but i also feel like miranda
lambert's like my hatred of miranda
lambert was like a byproduct of her
negative media cobra coverage like
misogynistic okay so she literally
wanted to date a bunch of guys in a row
who cares um so i just feel like i was
tricked also jason aldean is up there
used to really like not [__] with him
but i kind of think like i like his
music yeah i used to like really not
like him um
like for literally no reason other than
the fact that i just decided not to like
excited i just like i'm a hate-filled
person like i'm
i'm trying to be better like i really am
yeah and just like question yeah
everything yeah but i feel like there
are other people that you hate like
where you have ground charlie booth yeah
right right no i have my reasons yeah
and i don't really feel as bad for like
hating men for no reason than i do for
hating women because like then it's just
like my internalized misogyny yeah like
why why did i hate selena gomez because
she was a little messy like aren't we
all yeah but it was also because of the
rivalry of growing up i think it was
like so ingrained yes because you were
either one or the other like we
literally would have taken a bullet for
hannah
multiple like there was no better show
better disney star better musician
better person better celebrity than
hannah montana and i think we felt like
the other girls like demi and selena
were just like coming for hannah's neck
yeah and we weren't into it and then
like the jonas brothers got involved and
made it like
really tense and so we stuck with miles
no i was like
there was no question do you remember
when you met hannah miley like shortly
after hannah montana in her like iconic
long wavy hair era at topshop yeah i do
does that go down in history it's like
one of the best days of your life yeah
for sure because there was no celebrity
who i was more obsessed with or i've
ever maybe now the way i feel about like
kim
and kylie is how i felt then but now
it's more of a mature but it was your
number one it was my every it was my
personality like yeah i was miley
stewart you weren't gonna she's just
being miley i was just she's just being
jackie like
couldn't tell me that
i know so i'm glad you had that moment
yeah do you think that's like the most
starstruck you've ever been
i don't recall beings that starstruck
which is weird because i'm so shy and i
was alone so no one was there to like
help who took a picture of me
that's a great question because it was
like it wasn't a selfie no it wasn't it
was a blackberry i mean maybe i was with
olivia then if some because someone has
to take the picture and
it doesn't sound like my personality to
go up to miley alone no no so maybe i
was with olivia because we were downtown
well olivia will like is actually the
perfect person to be with like in a
situation like that because she's like
she will support 100 take the picture
she'll approach that's probably how
that's probably how it happened because
i know myself and i would never have
approached on my own especially when you
were like much younger yeah i always
think about that i think the most
starstruck i've ever been was when i met
harry styles
yeah that was like
one of the best and worst experiences of
my life because i looked like a loser
and like i acted like a loser and i'm
sure he was like not interested in
pursuing a friendship and you were a
loser right and i still am so it's good
to know that i'm consistent yeah but
just know like no matter how cool you
were in the moment like you weren't
going to be friends
okay so normally
normally i agree but it's not like i
went up to harry like hey can i get a
picture i love you like i went over and
i was like hey
it's me and he was like claudia like he
knew me
and he like it wasn't so much as like a
fan moment i didn't even get a picture
it was just like introducing myself as
the person he follows on instagram for
the last couple years and he knew me
immediately at first he thought i was a
fan and he turned his head away and then
he looked back and was like
claudia yeah yeah and i actually did
find out do you know how harry styles
found out that
caitlyn jenner had transitioned and her
name was caitlyn from my instagram i
know that for a fact i have inside
sources who told me that
isn't that cool that's very cool yeah so
i'm just like teaching harry things
i'm harry's teacher
i'm harry's guidance counselor
that's beautiful yeah are you ready for
our fifth and final story
i guess probably the most starstruck
i've really ever been was when i met a
harry austria wine rub oh yeah yeah for
sure yeah i was like quaking quaking i
miss him so much what others i mean
you've met a lot of celebrities but what
other celebrities have you met when you
weren't a celebrity right no like as a
true fan um
let me think yeah i feel like growing up
like we didn't have a lot of celebrity
like
interactions you know like i don't
recall being young and like meeting so
many famous people you know yeah
we never like went backstage at a
concert or anything no
i feel like the
what's so weird is like what's coming to
mind is like when we were in like high
school in middle school we went out to
dinner and we saw that guy from
america's next top model
nigel barker and like that's like and we
didn't even care we were like cool no or
that one time we were at a restaurant
but it was like the veronica's oh my god
the veronica's the veronica we read a
restaurant we saw the wrong
boo and we took a picture right yeah our
mom made us go we were obsessed we were
obsessed with the veronicas and then we
saw them at nobu and like it was the
best day of our lives oh my god that was
so the quran that was the moment like
that was i think we were all literally
like shaking and our mom like made us go
we were like 11. yeah that that it was
nobu yes yeah look at his fancy eating
at nobu at 11. i was probably having the
worst time i'm like can we go to
mcdonald's yeah
that is so iconic i forgot i think it
was my birthday yeah
that's iconic it was a tribeca no but
nobody
yeah what were we doing in tribeca no
that's like so not us
we were probably trying to make it nice
you know yeah birthday yeah but we
didn't live in the city yeah so
untouched and i want you so much somehow
i
can resist you it's not enough to say
that i miss you they were so good like
and we love a sister sister duo so
[__] good that is like the celebrity
moment of our counter of a lifetime
so niche like we're so alternative emo
indeed
like side parts we are indie girls yeah
so don't ever come for us and say that
we're not yeah like we're not mainstream
we're not like other girls no not at all
like i listen to
mumford
i listened to the veronicas literally
but then also we did encounter them like
later in life when we were
people we did yeah i remember went to
that concert you like with ryan cabrera
and you like interviewed him yeah yeah
yeah
at webster hall or something yeah but
that was like after you went because you
were an influencer right right no no
it's definitely more fun to like like
have a real fan moment as like a young
person like nothing to lose it's just
like you're meeting your icon and it's
like the best feeling in the world and
like those moments stick with you like
for your whole life yeah it's the best i
feel like snitch has had a lot of those
moments not i feel like now she like
still um runs into people and she's like
what do i do what do i say can i get a
picture
yeah yeah remember when we saw shane
mitchell that's what the one i was going
to say oh yeah you're at a restaurant
mitch was like so excited she was just
having brunch with her friends i don't
think snitch did anything about it no
she didn't and i'm sure she regrets it
yeah we all have moments like that that
we regret recently i think probably the
most starstruck i've been in recent
memory was when i saw rupaul at a
restaurant and like i couldn't go over
because it was like a restaurant that
has like a no approach rule um but even
him just like standing near me like i
was i was like shaking like yeah that's
like meeting like madonna like he's
literally like a living legend yeah i
wish i like i i think like that one will
stick with me like regret the regret but
you couldn't have done anything yeah i
couldn't okay
now it's time for our fifth and final
story which is a little tech news
spotify launches a new karaoke mode to
all spotify users you'll now be able to
sing along to your favorite tunes with
the app's new karaoke feature the
streaming platform's latest update
includes a karaoke mode which allows
users to sing their favorite songs with
the lyrics appearing on the screen in
addition to displaying the words the new
feature also gives you a scorecard and
rates you're singing that's kind of mean
oh love that that's a little like mean
what are they doing the judging are they
deciding are they putting on
instrumental version
unclear because i saw this news i'm like
this is such a good idea they could
literally like put the karaoke companies
like out of business
but if they're not offering like you
should be able to just toggle between
instrumental and non-instrumental but
not every artist puts out the
instrumental version of their song i
don't think spotify can just be like
tinkering with songs i feel like
literally moving forward they could just
be like when you want to upload a song
also upload the
is that how much they're going to
prioritize this karaoke probably not but
as a karaoke fiend i think this is great
and i'll definitely be using the feature
and also it's a great way to learn the
lyrics to songs like you're just
starting oh yeah this is going to put a
z lyrics out of business no easy lyrics
could never go out of business and
dana's going to be excited about this
news yeah no and it's like it's nice to
sing along to a song like if you're not
like 100 sure of the words just to have
them available yeah i like that
i like the beat i like the beat
uh the butterfly's just constantly
raising the bar like for everyone i'm
sorry i mean
breaking bread and music in podcasting
and tech like they never stop thinking
about their users yeah and it's like
when i think of like the podcasting wars
between like all the networks and you
know
spotify obviously has made the most
progress in the last couple years and it
just makes me think like what is apple
doing
no they're doing nothing they do
nothing there are
apple podcasts like originals are there
no and like why not why haven't they
entered the game because it was so easy
for them when podcasts started becoming
popular like there was
a podcast
like i didn't even realize that there
was other podcasting right and so now
that like all these like amazon's
getting really into podcast all these
big like streamers are getting into
podcasts what the [__] is apple doing
with their podcast like a couple maybe
like a year or two ago they launched
like a patreon thing where like you can
now pay for content it was so bad first
of all they were taking so much money
away from creators like i would never do
it and like they're just doing nothing
they're giving us nothing like they
should start doing like either buying up
like how they're buying uh call her
daddy
armchair expert like how spotify's doing
that amazon should be making their own
shows buying other shows not amazon
sorry apple and there's two things
what are you doing because even them
doing the subscription model like that
would have been great before patreon
existed like right you're just copying
everyone and you're just too lating or
not as good as copying it as facebook is
right also if you go to the browse page
on podcasts like to me the best part
about apple podcasts are the charts like
those are you can't see spotify i mean
people's podcast numbers right you can
see followers on other platforms like
the only thing we have is the charts
right and apple redesigned their explore
page a while ago and they like buried
the charts and they like have their home
page is like messy chaotic they have all
these editorial pics of podcasts that
they push forward and it's like get this
garbage out of here and it should be
tailored to me because here's what i
subscribe to taste of taylor the morning
toast sophia with an f this snatcher
caviar dreams with margaret mood the
redheads uh hey babe with saul and chris
so like
how is uh revisionist history top
scientists design their dream
experiments something i would be
interested in yeah
it should be like targeted and it should
be tailored to things that i
like like i'm not going to walk i'm not
going to listen to axios the cost of the
economic war with russia i have
revisionist history as well and also
like why are we on the homepage like no
it's like
what are these podcasts and then i'm
scrolling all the way down now i can get
to the charts i find the charts
interesting because you're right like
when it comes to podcasts like you would
be really surprised a lot of the the
creators who follow follow no matter how
many like followers they have on certain
social media platforms that doesn't
always translate to podcast listeners
great equalizer yeah so it's like they
have fancy you know videos and it looks
like it's a really big podcast you would
be surprised like literally nobody
listens to their podcast and a telltale
sign of like a podcast that you like
follow not being popular is like if
they're constantly moving networks
because a network will drop a podcast
that doesn't have enough views to
monetize it
so if like a podcast you follow is
always like oh i'm at a new network now
my podcast one oh that's a telltale sign
i don't see a lot of podcasts that like
are constantly moving networks i see a
couple but a telltale sign is how many
reviews you have it doesn't matter what
the rating is because a lot of people
like hate review podcasts but like and
if you have a lot of reviews even if
they're hate reviews like you ha you're
making noise but that's literally
spotify again
be doing the most like you can only
review a podcast on spotify that spotify
has literal proof and data that you have
listened to a couple times gorgeous so
you can't just like ransack someone's
page because you like got mad that they
said something about pitbulls or
whatever and then start leaving negative
reviews and apples should adapt and
steal that technology immediately yeah
it's really smart it's so simple
okay those are the fast life stories so
go seeing your heart out on karaoke yeah
i will definitely don't worry about it
i'm not huge on karaoke but once i'm
there i can get into it i don't know no
it's definitely like not fun to do
something you're not like great at oh
but that's the point of karaoke that's
why like i don't like you know spin
you know yeah it's not fun doing
something like you're not really good at
it no but to me i sound good and i i do
get into it but it's like then i have to
listen to other people that is the thing
like what you're not mariah carey sit
down yeah no listening to other people
is beyond painful it's painful it's
enjoyable to do your own i think
everyone enjoys they feel like a star
even other people who have good voices
like i don't care i don't give a [__]
and what song do you choose no it's so
true chooses this song it's so [__]
true that's my problem with karaoke you
should just do it me and you
everything's a duet we'll enjoy the
whole time or like me and you separate
rooms separate mics
a solo karaoke well now you can do that
with spotify but also the fun of karaoke
is having an audience of course
um so it's good something's good to do
on your birthday you make everyone come
and make everyone listen to you and
someone have a concerto no one else can
have the mic i love that
um we have
those are the past five and we're about
to interview jill zarin so we got a prep
for that yeah um i don't believe there's
anything else we have to cover nope
didn't watch any more content didn't
read any more books new episode of the
redheads
is dropping you know who knows when let
me know if you want it sometime let me
know if you want it sooner rather than
later but we are recording tonight so if
you have questions about this month's
book email us the redheadsbookclub
gmail.com you can also ask us like any
book questions in general where we like
answering questions yes the point of the
book club so and next month's is dana's
choice and she gave me a sneak peek of
what she's choosing and it looks like a
thriller oh it does it's not super
dangerous choice because she always
picks like very intellectual books but
this looks like really good and twisted
um if you're looking for more content
the snatcher came out today new episode
i'm on shannon ford's podcast probably a
podcast listening i heard you guys talk
about me and say nice things so i have
to get to that part yeah all the tnn
shows are updating weekly so check that
out check out our patreon and thank you
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the fafsa stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be found so spotify itunes stitch or
public radio i ready to catch box all
the places wherever those guys find some
more chosen faster reviews
have a great day everyone we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day
it